kayla is with us in Austin Texas hi
Kayla how are you my car sure how can I
help
so my husband that I really want to have
a second baby but with but with daycare
at $2,000 a month for two kids we're
just concerned that we may not be able
to afford it okay and what do you make I
make 60 K here okay and then my husband
makes 38k okay and you pay your bills
now yeah we do we're fine with pinger
bills and on time another thing when you
have excellent credit scores but we do
have fifty two thousand dollars in debt
okay and you don't have any savings our
savings is about three thousand we just
like to keep that little cushion well we
teach folks around here to walk what we
call the baby steps have you ever heard
me talk about that yeah okay so baby
step one would be a thousand dollars
saved only no other investing no other
savings and then we begin to get out of
debt if you were walking on that track
and I think you can then can you afford
an additional thousand dollars a month
for an additional child in daycare is
what you're telling me it costs in your
area is that right yeah so you're paying
a thousand I also do kids would be two
thousand right right mm-hmm
seems a little steep yeah I mean it's a
for like a daycare center it's typically
about a thousand a month per child and
looked into some home daters that's like
seven hundred a month so I just had
trouble finding license term daycares
there's a lot of unlicensed mud and that
was just a little concerned about that
[Music]
and what is the trajectory on your all's
careers are you seeing substantial moves
or just slight moves in your incomes so
my husband just started his job two
months ago and as a data analyst so he's
pretty
this is you know his first job in this
field so I think after the idea - he
should be able to move up between 10 and
20,000 oh it's right yeah that's a
pretty cheap data analyst job yeah yeah
and then I am almost a CPA I passed all
my CPA exams so with that and then also
I joined my dad's CPA firm and I'm
hoping I can help him grow the business
you make a lot modified so there's some
you know there's some room for growth
there don't you okay so if you're doing
all of that you can afford a thousand
dollars more a month um right I mean
right now with our budget it's pretty
tight you have an excess of 825 a month
so we're almost there we're close but I
mean I guess our rents probably too high
and our water bills like 330 a month I
don't know what's up with that mmm
that's out of control and how much is
your rent it's 1,800 yeah that's more
steep yeah
what the numbers are giving me it is
yeah so you know here that the point is
this you can afford a kid mm-hmm
you can't afford to do some of the stuff
you're doing if you if you have a kid
though you're just making a choice
you're making a choice we're gonna live
somewhere different we're gonna work
more we're gonna get our incomes up
we're gonna cut some other spending or
I'll figure out this water problem and
we're gonna cheaper rent those are two
thoughts and we're gonna do something
get our income up that's the other thing
you're already doing some things to get
your income up both of you are and as
long as you see that trajectory but yeah
yeah you don't enter into something
where you say I have no idea how I'm
gonna pay for that and we're just gonna
cross our fingers well that would be
stupid and that's why you're calling me
okay but my point is I think you can
make this work I mean you have a 98
thousand dollar household income people
with $98,000 households incomes can
afford to kids with daycare mm-hmm when
you just look at it that way alone you
go oh there's some other crap going on
here I want you do in your cars I owe
16,000 on my car and my husband owes
8,000 and our car payments are about
each 250 a month okay you could sell
your car
get your cheap car mm-hmm
starts to get in balance when you do
some stuff like that see the debt is
draining you down and you're doing
nothing to address the debt right now
they already making the minimum yeah and
that you're never complete they're doing
that so yeah you know the shortest path
is to get on a plan dial the lifestyle
down doll the income up begin to beat on
the debt and if the debt getting out of
debt slows down somewhat because a baby
comes oh well so what so it sounds to me
like you guys need to get real serious
about the money because you've kind of
just been playing yeah in the past we
have we got and the last few months
they've gotten a lot more strict service
check with our budget here yeah yeah but
he just got a job back and yeah you know
you really have done a horrible job to
this point mm-hmm you're not being
serious about it you just kind of fat
and flabby and and your money mm-hmm and
and I'm what you get like you know
really start working out working out
hard so hold on I'm gonna send you a
copy the book the Total Money Makeover
and it will show you how to win hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]